we're in a frozen continent Megan what
it's my first dinner in Antarctica
my name is JJ Kelly and I am a producer
at National Geographic I had the chance
to go down to Antarctica one of a very
select few that made the series
continent 70 so comments Evan Antarctica
for me is a really exciting series
because Antarctic is a place that not a
lot of people know about you really
don't know what makes it tick down there
you don't know what the people are like
and it's not just a surface glance at
what happens in Antarctica we follow
these people we learn about their
stories we see their failures we see
their successes first time I went down
there I was on the Ross Ice Shelf
imagine a piece of ice that's the size
of France my wife was so sweet and she
knew that I would be living in a tent
and sometimes negative 30 negative 40 40
50 60 70 mile an hour winds away from
all communication so she wrote a letter
every day in the morning when I woke up
in my tent I was able to read this
letter and it connected me with home and
that was the one comfort that really got
me through the day so I think that the
people down in Antarctica I thought were
the most fascinating and gets in their
blood and they go back again and again
and I got a little bit of that too again
down there